[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much I thought by way of
transition I would tell all of you that
I wouldn't be here tonight today if it
were not for Peter Collier in the 90s of
actually going back further in the early
80s I worked at Revolution Books which
was the book store of the Revolutionary
Communist Party and I was very hardcore
leftist and along the course of things I
read destructive generation which had an
explosive effect on me as it had on so
many people and then some years later I
was working as a an ad writer a
copywriter and a ghostwriter and read
the Quran for fun and after 9/11 was
asked to write a book by somebody who
knew me and I worked with to write a
book explaining what had happened and
why and I said well I'm nobody why would
anybody pay attention to what I think
about any of this and the guy said just
write it and if it's quality work and if
it explains the material then I will get
somebody to publish it and of course the
person he got to publish it was Peter
Collier and my first book Islam unveiled
came out in 2002 from encounter books
and I remember talking to him on the
phone after he read the manuscript and
being sort of staggered and amazed when
he said that he liked it and you can
hear all these people saying that that
he completely rewrote he did rewrite
about half of it but still he liked it
I'm still thrilled in any case the other
part of that story is that the gentleman
who asked me to write the book and
encouraged me to do so worked for a
different publishing house arrival
publishing
to encounter and they were going to
publish the book but then the head of
the publishing house who was a leading
conservative publisher he said in a
meeting while I was there that he had
visited Gaza and the Palestinians were
wonderful people and he didn't want to
offend them by publishing this book and
that's a lot of the fix that we're in
and what I addressed in this new book
the Palestinian delusion which you all
got in the bags when you registered
you may remember Jimmy Carter standing
there beaming happily with Anwar Sadat
of Egypt and Menachem Begin the Prime
Minister of Israel at Camp David in the
late 70s and there was going to be peace
and you may remember Bill Clinton
standing there with the Itzhak rubin and
Yasser Arafat and there shaking hands
and Clinton his beaming and there's
going to be peace and you may remember
George W Bush standing there with
Mahmoud Abbas and Ariel Sharon and
beaming as they shake hands and there's
going to be peace and you may remember
Obama standing there with a boss again
and Benjamin Netanyahu same thing and
the one thing we've never had is peace
we've had 40 years of peace process and
no peace the reason why is revealed in
many of the things that took place in
the first and most celebrated aspect of
that peace process and that of course is
the Camp David summit and Anwar Sadat's
overtures to Israel after the 1973 war
this is of course very important in
world history if you go to Jerusalem you
can go to the beggin Sadat Center in
Jerusalem that studies ways to bring
about peace and so on and Sadat is a
revered figure around the world but I
would expect that many of you will be
surprised to know why exactly it was
that he reached out to the Israelis and
began the peace process he is a he's a
great Saint now you know he's a Ghandi
figure and so on but the real story is a
little bit different as is always the
case
Anwar Sadat of course was president of
Egypt and in the night being the Yom
Kippur War he was one of the Muslim Arab
countries that attacked Israel
gratuitous lien without cause and they
were of course making great inroads
because it was Yom Kippur they were
making great inroads at the beginning
and then the Israelis began to regroup
and to beat them back and then the
ceasefire was concluded and so on and
shortly after this there was a Politburo
meeting meeting of the high command of
the Soviet Union now of course at this
time the israeli-palestinian conflict
was part of the Cold War with the
Israelis on the American side and the
Palestinians on the Soviet side and
everything was binary not like it is now
and you had Gromyko the Foreign Minister
of the Soviet Union speaking with Leonid
Brezhnev of the premier of the Soviet
Union about what to do about the
israeli-palestinian conflict and he
actually asked him at this Politburo
meeting we've got the minutes in the
book laying it what are we going to do
about the Israelis and the Palestinians
and Brezhnev says we're gonna
participate in negotiations at the
appropriate time we will restore
diplomatic relations with Israel and
everybody the whole Politburo was
shocked and Gromyko says but the Arabs
will get angry like oh the Sun will come
up but anyway the Arabs will get angry
and this is what Brezhnev responded and
this is very important Brezhnev says
they can go to hell we have offered them
a sensible way for so many years but no
they
wanted to fight fine we gave them
technology the latest the kind even
Vietnam didn't have they had double
superiority in tanks and aircrafts
triple in artillery and in air defense
and anti-tank weapons they had absolute
supremacy and what once again they were
beaten once again they scrammed once
again they screamed for us to come and
save them Sadat woke me up in the middle
of the night twice over the phone save
me he demanded we sent Soviet troops
immediately no we're not gonna fight for
them the people would not understand
that and especially we will not start a
world war over them so that's that we
will do what I said you noticed that he
said Sadat lead it for us pleaded for
help after he had given them all the
best weaponry and they still lost and so
what did Sadat do he was very astute he
realized ok the Soviets want me to make
peace with Israel but who really has the
leverage over Israel to get them to make
concessions not Soviets but the United
States so Sadat took Brezhnev's advice
but he switched sides and that was when
Sadat you may recall those of you who
are as old as I am you may recall that
in the early 70s Sadat broke with the
Soviets and approached the United States
and made an accord with the United
States and it was considered to be a
great Cold War breakthrough but Sadat
himself explained when he was asked why
he was doing this he said what other
country can force Israel to withdraw
that's what it was all about and that's
what the peace process was all about
Sadat very famously offered to go to
Israel and of course Israel being
besieged and battered and and and
excoriated in world opinion and
everything else for so many decades
they were thrilled and the Israelis
greeted Sadat rapturously when he went
to Jerusalem and he addressed the
Knesset and was roofs received as a
tremendous hero but if you actually look
at what he said it's astonishing what he
was saying essentially in his speech in
the Knesset was let's negotiate you give
me everything I want and our
negotiations will be concluded because
what he said was let me tell you without
the slightest hesitation this is Sadat
and the Knesset that I did not come to
you under this dome to make a request
that your troops evacuate the occupied
territories complete withdrawal from the
Arab territories occupied in 1967 is a
logical and undisputed fact nobody
should plead for that any talk about
permanent peace based on justice and any
move to ensure our coexistence in peace
and security in this part of the world
would become meaningless while you
occupy Arab territories by force of arms
now he's talking about the 1967 borders
which of course is still a very hot
issue and demanding that Israel withdraw
completely from the so called occupied
territories but the fact is that of
course it is a staple of the Muslim Arab
rhetoric about Israel that Israel action
actually is entirely occupying land that
belongs rightly to the Muslim Arabs and
thus none of it has any legitimacy so
when he's saying that there can be no
peace until all the UOC Arab territories
that you occupy by force of arms are
cleared out he's saying Israel has to
stop existing and then we'll be friends
and yet nobody really paid attention to
this nobody pondered the implications at
the time and of course most famously
Jimmy Carter invited Sadat and Bagan to
Camp David a few years after that about
a year after this rather and that was
going to be peace it was going to be
great but the thing was
harder was entranced by Sadat Carter did
think that Sadat was some extraordinary
magnanimous Gandhi like world figure for
peace and so he told him essentially
that he would give him anything he
wanted he called him a great and good
man and Carter said to Sadat I will
represent your interests as if they were
my own you are my brother now contrast
that to Carter's National Security
Adviser
he remembers a big new Brzezinski yeah
you remember him and he said in his
memoirs that Carter's relationship with
bagan was quote I see an even mutual
praise was formalistic and devoid of any
personal feeling but meanwhile Carter is
telling Sadat I hope I'll never let you
down and what's really ironic about this
is that Sadat went back to Mohamed Kamel
his foreign minister than the rest of
his entourage and he's telling them all
this with great hilarity and talking to
them about the person he called poor
naive Carter and it was it was really
sort of ludicrous how he took advantage
of Carter at Camp David and what
happened essentially is Bagan caught on
very quickly he went back to his own
group and he said the Americans have
adopted the Egyptian program that's that
and that's essentially what was forced
upon the Israelis at the time I mean it
was really an unfair conflict it was two
against one
and so there wasn't really any chance
Bagan actually brought along Samuel Katz
who's the author of a great book called
battleground about the case essentially
the case for Israel and he had cats
talking to Carter to try to explain to
him why Israel had a just case that
ought to be respected and Carter just
got more and more impatient until he cut
him off entirely he had no interest in
listening to this at
in any case what happened was that the
Sadat is walking and this is an
indication of what his true mindset was
Sadat is walking in the woods in Camp
David with Kamel his foreign minister
and some others and he's saying this we
are dealing with the lowest and meanest
of enemies the Jews the Jews even
tormented their prophet Moses and
exasperated their God I pity poor Carter
in his dealings with Bagan with his
stilted mentality and so then Kamel asks
him what do you think that Carter is
gonna pressure bagan to give us what
what we want and Sadat says oh yeah of
course he will it was in the bag now
what's really interesting about this
story is that moments after this right
they're having this conversation who
walks up to them but as they're weitzman
the israeli foreign minister who was
also walking in the woods and he says to
Sadat can we talk face-to-face later on
today and Sadat suddenly changes seconds
ago he's talking about the lowest and
meanest of enemies the Jews and now he
says of course it's always a pleasure to
talk to you
he was completely duplicitous and he's
really actually it's been
extraordinarily effective his historical
memory is a monument of duplicity no in
any case you know what happened that the
Israelis were made to give up the Sinai
which they had occupied and make other
concessions now remember that we're
talking about what happened after a
defensive war why did Israel take the
Sinai did it have imperialist designs on
Egypt did it want to colonize the entire
Middle East as the lot of the paranoid
Palestinian propaganda says
obviously not what you have is the same
thing that happened if you look at a map
of Germany before World War two and a
map of Germany after World War two and
one thing that you'll notice is that
Germany is smaller after World War two
why is that did the de Poland and the
Soviet Union and the rest of them with
Soviet Union may have but Poland was not
working from some imperialist project
the entire continent of Europe had been
victimized by the Germans and it was
considered to be entirely just that they
lose some territory and that the
surrounding nations gained some
territory as a matter of protecting
their own security and this is a law of
human history really that you find
multiple examples of throughout history
that the victorious nation can expand
its territory at the expense of the
defeated nation so as to protect itself
more effectively from future attacks of
the same kind only when it comes to
Israel was this not allowed but Sadat
and Carter compelled Bagan to give up
the Sinai which had been taken for
security purposes and to make various
concessions one of the most
extraordinary concessions that Bagan
made or was forced to make was the
recognition of an entity called the
Palestinian people and I'm sure that you
all know that there is no such thing as
the Palestinian people the Arabs of the
region in the first place the name
Palestine was a name given by the Romans
to the land of Judea
after the Bar Kokhba revolt in 134 of
the Common Era in the Year 134 there was
a Jewish leader Bar Kokhba who led a
revolt against the Romans and they lost
and so the Romans had had enough this
was not the first revolt and they
expelled the Jews from the area when
they renamed Jerusalem Aelia Capitolina
and they renamed Judea
Palestine where did they get the name
Palestine they went into the Bible and
they saw that the Jews enemies were the
Philistines and they named then the
region accordingly but at that point it
was just a regions name it was like
Brooklyn to say that there's a
Palestinian people that is distinct from
the other Arabs of the region is as
silly as saying that Brooklyn Heights
are ethnically or culturally different
and are a separate nation unto
themselves well maybe they are and when
it comes to Palestine that were always
Jews living there because the Romans had
expelled the Jews from the area but the
expulsion decree was not universally
enforced and there was a Jewish presence
in Palestine from that that moment 1:34
up to the present day
uninterrupted meanwhile after the 7th
century conquest of the area by the
Muslim Arabs then Arabs moved into the
area and were there intermittently they
were conquered by the Turks and so on
the people who lived there were Arabs
the Arabs were not different
linguistically culturally or religiously
from Arabs anywhere else in that area
there was no distinct Palestinian people
there never was and as far as the legal
right to the land was concerned you have
various conquests and the right of
conquest is something else that's always
been recognized in human history so we
can say the land belonged to the Arab
Muslim caliphates
and that it belonged to the Turkish
Caliphate the Ottoman Empire and then
what happened the Ottoman Empire fell at
the end of World War 1 and the Turks
ceded
right to that area to the League of
Nations the precursor to the United
Nations and the League of Nations gave
Britain what is known as the mandate for
Palestine which was intended to be the
create the to allow for the creation of
a Jewish homeland in Palestine that was
what it was explicitly for so there is
nobody else who has any legal claim to
that land other than the Jews other than
the State of Israel and even more than
this you have an unbroken historical
record of Jewish presence there you have
the fact that nobody else has any claim
to that territory I'm speaking about the
fact that people say nowadays that
there's that the the Israel exists on
stolen land it wasn't who was it stolen
from if I pick up a wallet on the street
it belongs to somebody but nobody owns
this wallet it was it's it's the land
that was set aside for the Jewish
Mandate for Palestine and remember that
includes what is known as the West Bank
or Judea and Samaria and Gaza and as a
matter of fact it includes Jordan as
well although Jordan was detached from
the land dedicated to the Mandate for
Palestine by the British early on you
know that phrase perfidious Albion
perfidious Albion is a phrase used for
Britain and I'm sorry if Katie's here
sorry but anyway but there's no doubt
that Albion was perfidious in this case
because of course you have the Zionist
project beginning in the 19th century in
them in the background of everything
that I'm saying you have the Zionists
beginning to say this is our land this
is our historic homeland we need to
return to this place so that we have our
own nation and are not subject to
persecution by everybody else
and so Jews from Europe Jews from all
over begin to move into the land of
Palestine and the British are supposed
to be behind this the British are
supposed to be saying this is what is
supposed to happen but after it started
to happen the Arabs started to complain
and the Arabs started to complain very
simply because of a Quran verse if you
open your Quran to chapter 2 verse 191
you'll see it drive them out from where
they drove you out now it is a
historical myth in several stages that
the Israelis drove anybody out there was
nobody driven out it was the Jews who
were driven out by the Romans in the
first place
most of them although many stayed as I
said but anyway once the Arabs started
complaining on this very basic principle
you see drive them out from where they
drove you out if you think about that
for a minute it means no Jews should be
here this is land that belongs to
Muslims because Muslims once ruled it
and if Muslims once ruled it they have
the responsibility before Allah to drive
out those who rule it now so they had to
drive out the Jews from the area and the
British that was a British colonel
Colonel Bertie Harry waters Taylor and
he spoke to them you know he went to the
mufti of Jerusalem Haj Amin al-husseini
is someone you may have heard of and I'm
sorry Douglas Murray couldn't make it so
I had to do it
Colonel Bertie Harry waters Taylor went
to Haj Amin al-husseini the mufti of
Jerusalem and the mufti of Jerusalem is
somebody you may be familiar with
because he lived in Berlin during World
War two was friends with Himmler and
Eichmann and encouraged the final
solution the genocide of the Jews but
this is in 1920 this is before all that
and Colonel birdy Harry waters Taylor
told him you know we've got a bit of a
sticky wicket here because we encouraged
the settlement but now
you are complaining and we want to make
you happy so what we need to do is if
you commit a few terror attacks then the
British government will see that the
Zionist project is not viable and will
withdraw yes the British government
encouraged the Arab Muslims of Palestine
to commit terror attacks against the
Jews and told them they would be
rewarded for doing so
now you see if you think about that if
that is the beginning of all this then
you see why in a microcosm world opinion
is so crazy nowadays because this is
something that the seeds of were planted
years ago that intimidation will work
they were told that if they were
bullying and if they were violent then
they would be rewarded and they have
been Sadat's overture for peace was just
another way to go about the principle
attaining the principle of divert drive
them out from where they drove you out
and they have worked on the basis of
intimidation ever since ever since one
thing happened Donald Trump was elected
president
[Music]
[Applause]
now you'll notice intimidation has been
the basis of American foreign policy
between is regarding Israel and the
Palestinians really ever since the State
of Israel was founded after the State of
Israel was founded with very few
exceptions we have bout two Arab Muslim
intimidation and allowed them to dictate
exactly what we would do regarding
Israel Sadat and Carter is one example
of that and pretty much every other
peace process initiative as you'll see
in the book is are more examples of it
and one of the most egregious examples
of it came when the US Congress in the
90s recognized Jerusalem as Israel's
capital but added a caveat that
Jerusalem would not be recognized as
Israel's capital if the president
thought it an expedient for whatever
reason to postpone that recognition and
Bill Clinton postponed it George W Bush
postponed it Obama postponed it on what
grounds
because the Palestinians would riot
because of intimidation they had been
taught from the beginning they had been
told by the British if you're violent if
you commit acts of terror you'll be
rewarded Trump changed all that Trump
said I'm moving the capital I'm not
gonna bow to your bullying and
intimidation
[Applause]
and so finally we have a chance to
achieve some sanity in this conflict but
for the rest of the story for a record
of insanity you have the book
all in your bags and thank you very much
for being here this morning
[Music]
[Applause]